c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir le pouvoir militaire au
soudan prêt à laisser place à un
gouvernement civil c'est en tout cas ce
qu'a annoncé le général abdel fattah al
bayane une décision qui intervient en
cinquième jour d'un sit in contre les
putschistes les détails de notre
correspondante dans la région dès le
début de ce journal le soulagement au
mali la cedeao a décidé de lever les
sanctions économiques et financières
contre la junte malienne l'organisation
ouest africaine a été convaincu par l'
annonce de bamako d'un calendrier
électoral pour un retour à un
gouvernement civil d'ici 2024 et à la
fin de cette édition nous irons à
londres le musée victoria and albert
consacre une exposition à la mode
africaine 40 designers parmi les plus en
vogue vont exposer les détails à la fin
de ce journal
que vaut la promesse du général
abdelfattah al bolzano manifestants
soudanais au pouvoir depuis le putsch du
25 octobre dernier l'a annoncé ce lundi
qu'il était prêt à laisser place à un
gouvernement civil une décision qui
intervient au cinquième jour d'un sit in
contre les putschistes les détails de
notre correspondante dans la région
elodie cousin
c'est à la télévision que le général
burhan actuellement à la tête du soudan
s'est exprimé ce lundi soir un discours
surprise qui survient après cinq jours
de manifestations au soudan alors le
général bourhane a reconnu que le pays
était très difficile à diriger que les
choses allaient très mal plus de huit
mois après le coup d'état du 25 octobre
dernier et que pour cette raison et bien
les militaires devaient se retirer du
dialogue national qui a lieu en ce
moment à khartoum mais qu'un
gouvernement civil composé de
personnalités compétentes devaient être
formés il a notamment précisé que le
conseil souverain de transition devait
être dissous et qu'à la place un conseil
militaire devaient être formés afin
d'assurer la sécurité et la défense du
pays c'est un discours surprise ce n'est
pas pour autant la première fois que les
militaires prennent les devants et font
des annonces des annonces qui n'ont pas
toujours été respectée depuis la
révolution qui a causé la chute d'omar
el béchir notamment dans son discours le
général bourhane a précisé qu'aucune
date et donner aucun détail quant à la
suite de cette transition
mais une annonce qui intervient
également dans un contexte de crise
économique grave depuis le coup d'état
les donateurs internationaux ont gelé
des fonds pour pousser les militaires à
reprendre des pourparlers avec les
responsables civils des problèmes
quotidiens de coupures d'eau et
d'électricité empoisonnent la vie des
soudaines et shirli sitbon
c'est un été très chaud soudan mais le
manque les tuyaux sont à sec les
habitants collecte l'eau là où il on
trouve
le manque d'eau est un problème grave
notamment pour des raisons de santé nous
ne pouvons pas laver correctement ni les
vêtements ni les toilettes il y a donc
des conséquences sanitaires
les tuyaux sont vides parce que les
caisses de l'état sont vides les
militaires au pouvoir ne peuvent plus
faire fonctionner les infrastructures
les coupures d'électricité se
multiplient
ce qui bloque les pompes à eau
ces coupures d'électricité répétées ont
des effets psychologiques nous sommes
stressés parce qu'on a besoin
d'électricité pour faire beaucoup de
choses et maintenant on ne peut plus les
faire
le soudan avait déjà des problèmes
économiques mais depuis le coup d'état
militaire du mois d'octobre il s'enfonce
dans la crise les manifestations se
multiplient les institutions
internationales et donateurs ont
suspendu leur aide jusqu'à ce que les
militaires reprennent les pourparlers
avec les responsables civils leurs
anciens partenaires qui l'ont destitué
en octobre
on devait recevoir en 2022 et 2023 près
de quatre milliards de dollars de la
banque mondiale
les militaires refusent même de prendre
des stocks de blé qu'ils ont commandés à
des agriculteurs faute d'argent pour les
payer
le blé pourri dans les fermes en ces
temps de pénurie due à la guerre en
ukraine
la levée des sanctions économiques et
financières contre le mali la cedeao a
pris à cette décision dimanche lors d'un
sommet à accra au ghana l'organisation
ouest africaine a pris en compte l'
annonce par les autorités maliennes d'un
calendrier électoral pour un retour à un
gouvernement civil en 2024 récit de
marque pop / après des heures de
délibération les dirigeants africains
ont finalement tranché les sanctions
économiques et financières mises en
place il ya six mois contre le mali vont
être levés la décision intervient après
l annonce de la junte militaire d'un
calendrier électoral pour un retour à un
gouvernement civil d'ici 2024
andy économiques inchangées les
sanctions économiques et financières
prises le 9 janvier 2022 tous
à savoir la fermeture des frontières que
l'on joue le gel des avoirs financiers
frise sont logés
un lift la communauté économique des
états d'afrique de l'ouest s'est aussi
dit favorable au plan du burkina faso la
junte au pouvoir projette un retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel en 24 mois les
menaces de sanctions économiques ont
donc été levée la cedeao en revanche
adressé une fin de non recevoir à la
guinée pour ses membres la volonté des
auteurs du coup d'état d'assurer une
transition vers la démocratie en trois
ans est inacceptable
les militaires guinéens ont à présent
jusqu'à fin juillet pour proposer un
nouveau calendrier sous peine de
sanctions
cette vague de coups d'état a débuté au
mali en 2020 avant de se propager à la
guinée en septembre 2021 puis au burkina
faso en janvier dernier par crainte de
voir la stabilité politique ébranlée
dans la région la cédéao a suspendu ces
trois pays du bloc
malgré la fin des sanctions
ces évictions des trois pays reste
d'actualité et seront levés une fois les
scrutins à effectuer
vous l'avez entendu la cedeao est
également un favorable au plan proposé
par les militaires du burkina faso le
pays subit ces dernières semaines une
multiplication des attaques djihadistes
au moins 27 personnes ont été tuées ce
week-end lors de deux attaques
distinctes qui ont visé des civils dans
le nord et le nord ouest du pays kalidou
sy
deux attaques en 24 heures dans la nuit
de dimanche à lundi des individus armés
ont attaqué le village de bosasso dans
le nord ouest du pays la veille samedi
une autre attaque meurtrière a également
eu lieu à nam sigma dans la région du
nord le bilan de ces deux attaques et
lourd une vingtaine de personnes tuées
selon des sources sécuritaires depuis
2015 les attaques jihadi se multiplient
au burkina faso le 24 janvier dernier le
président roch kaboré est renversé par
le lieutenant colonel paul landry
sandaogo damiba il reproche à son
prédécesseur son incapacité à enrayer la
violence djihadiste près de six mois
après sa prise de pouvoir
le pays est toujours confronté à un
regain de violences qui ont fait des
centaines de victimes la plus sanglante
le 11 juin dernier à seilh tonga où 86
personnes avaient été tuées en réponse
le désormais président damiba a annoncé
la création de deux zones d'intérêt
militaire dans les régions de l'est et
du sahel et la mise en place d'une
brigade de veille de défense patriotique
des mesures d'urgence alors que plus de
40% du territoire échappent au contrôle
de l'état selon des chiffres officiels
la pression djihadistes ne semble pas
baisser d'un cran et l'annoncent ce
vendredi de la fin de la task force
européenne takouba ne rassure pas si
elle marque un nouveau point de rupture
avec le mali ce désengagement ne rassure
pas le niger voisin les explications de
notre correspondant à un rôle girard le
mali n'héberge plus un seul soldat
européen de la force takouba cette force
qui aura rassemblé 800 soldats dont
l'objectif était de soutenir les forces
armées maliennes dans leur lutte contre
les groupes armés terroristes sur leur
territoire n'est plus dix pays européens
ont participé la france l'estonie ou
encore la république tchèque dont les
contingents de soldats sont venus sur le
terrain dans les opérations menées
contre ces groupes terroristes et des à
plusieurs reprises cette année
principalement la mort de cette force
armée de cette force takouba signe peut
être le début du 1 mise encore plus
forte de l'état islamique au grand
sahara côté malien dans la zone entre le
mali et le niger du côté nigérien on se
méfie d'une accentuation de la pression
jihadiste sur la frontière en renforçant
déjà plusieurs postes militaires proches
du voisin l'opération takouba elle
n'aura duré que deux ans le cadre
juridique spécifique qui avait été créé
pour elle n'existe plus du côté de
barkan et donc du côté de l'armée
française dans la même optique le départ
des derniers soldats français du mali
est prévue pour fin août
et on reste au niger où parmi les
conséquences du terrorisme l'insécurité
alimentaire plus de quatre millions de
personnes sont concernées alors que nous
sommes en pleine période de soudure
période où les récoltes 2021 sont
épuisés et celle de 2022 n'ont pas
encore débuté le programme alimentaire
mondial tente de répondre aux situations
d'urgence mais le pam souhaite aussi
proposer des solutions sur le long terme
reportage d'harold gérard
une usine et quelques paires de mains
pour lutter contre la crise alimentée à
tahoua ces femmes opère la première
étape de la chaîne de transformation du
mil en farine infantile fortifiée
l'objectif renforcer l'alimentation des
enfants de la région
cette farine a beaucoup davantage
surtout pour les enfants alors qu'elle
leur apporte beaucoup de vitamines comme
elle est composée de denrées locales
elle a beaucoup d'apports nutritionnels
et on connaît déjà les produits
nécessaires pour la confectionner une
unité de production mais aussi deux
formations rendu fonctionnelle par le
programme alimentaire mondial
les ouvrières produisent environ deux
tonnes de farine par semaine sous la
supervision de mme à denia abarchi la
responsable de lusine madénian espère
que ces femmes prendront bientôt elles
mêmes en charge la gestion de l'unité
donc si les femmes qui sont ici lettre à
passer leurs capes reste à savoir si
elles sont bien formés par rapport à la
fabrication de la farine je pense
qu'elle peut prendre la relève
[Musique]
près du village de fucci à 120 km de
tahoua c'est un autre programme du pam
qui combat les risques de famine salifou
nassirou forme les communautés rurales à
une agriculture moins dépendante de la
saison des pluies le changement
climatique reste la principale
difficulté dans la région
la saison des pluies pas si nous avons
eu beaucoup de pertes à cause du manque
de pluie de l'invasion des insectes et
des clics
mais la culture de contre saison que les
gens ont conduite un peu soulagé les
agriculteurs cette récolte est destiné à
l'autosuffisance alimentaire et non à la
vente
en juin 2022 l'insécurité alimentaire a
atteint son pic prévu touchant plus de 4
millions de personnes à travers le niger
de son côté le programme alimentaire
mondial accuse un manque de financement
à hauteur de 46 millions de dollars pour
faire face à cette période de soudure
pour finir je vous emmène à londres le
musée victoria and albert célèbre la
mode africaine cet été avec une
exposition qui met en lumière les
créateurs africains les plus en vogue le
musée va accueillir les créations de 40
designers contemporains 250 objets
seront exposés sophie lamothe
[Musique]
des robes faites avec du jeans recyclés
détour de tête en tissus traditionnels
ou encore un costume qui se veut à la
fois féminins et masculins la mode
africaine est à l'honneur cet été au
musée victoria and albert et elle en dit
long sur l'histoire et la culture du
continent oui mais c'est pas nous voyons
vraiment la mode comme un catalyseur par
lequel on peut raconter des histoires
plus profonde et plus riches sur des
nombreuses cultures à travers le
continent nous espérons que nos
visiteurs repartiront inspiré et que
certaines idées préconçues s'est en
remis en question
les inspirations remonte jusqu'aux
années 1950 avec les combats
d'indépendance notamment les tissus
kanté que kwame n'krumah portait lors de
son discours historique sur
l'indépendance du ghana où même les
chemises emblématique de nelson mandela
dans la même veine les vêtements pretty
si une tournure politique
[Musique]
mon travail est basé sur les deux
vêtements qui viennent de deux cultures
différentes la première est la culture
britannique et le trench coat et la
seconde est la burqa qui est aussi très
répandue au maroc et dans tous les pays
arabes
j'ai décidé d'aller dialoguer entre eux
deux une forme de respect pour jégo
dans une exposition qui met en lumière
des thèmes d'inclusivité et de
solidarité les designers africains se
réapproprient leur espace au vienna en
musée qui cherche à élargir sa
collection africaine
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci et de nous avoir suivis
merci aux équipes origine notre chef
d'édition célia karacena rester avec
nous l'info continue sur france 24
[Musique]
qui les mène à dire en toute l'actualité
politique économique culturelle et
sociale d'une région en mouvement
expresso riant le magazine du
moyen-orient présenté par meriem amellal
avoir sur france 24 et france 24 points
comme